quand un écrivain rencontre un autre
écrivain de quoi parle-t-il et bien pas
forcément d'histoire décrivent un témoin
les changes muscle est survenu hier soir
entre françois chalais et jean edern
hallier cela se passait au journée
mondiale du livre
a nice on y parlait publicité et
littérature mais ces deux écrivains ont
choisi pour discuter des arguments plus
frappant que littéraire regardez je suis
par collaborateur
quand vous savez que je vous rappelle
pas si je vends rien alors fait des
récents les inventer en tout cas son dû
les sags ont fait ce qu'on appelle des
choses que j'ai à dire un bonbon je
croyais t'inquiète pas répond-il
secondes je voudrais dire un mot parce
que quand même ça devient très grave
ces publicités littérature je comprends
que les bretons de jeu suivant alors
désolé
ils dénoncent les juges pour voir alors
quoi alors les parents avaient des
preuves
pas de calais
m
je suis là
chose je vois que monsieur d'allier à
utiliser le procédé les plus bas et
enfin une fois de plus pour créer
l'événement je croyais qu'il est
simplement l'imitateur de châteaubriant
je vois que j'ai suivies de tirs et le
luron
mais c'est pas fort parce que c'est
ignoble de paris
à 12 heures
le jour où je suis passé
ah voilà comme quoi la littérature
négocie pas forcément les moeurs mais
que des fidèles du petit théâtre de
bouvard soient rassurés notre ami
philippe a réussi à passer entre les
coups de poing et vous le retrouverez
demain soir comme d'habitude
[Musique]